I'm not upon which covet rules you were
opposed to
they all turned out to be stupid not all
which ones it was not on the mail no oh
no that item they just found they just
did a study the masks unless they were
n95 and maybe not even them useless
um you know I I stopped wearing a
masculine you didn't have to wear it
anymore and you all remember it's all
it's all degrees and it's well no The
Masks are increasingly less effective
the lower quality they are and we have
studies and we know that but it's
exactly this type of black and white
thinking offhanded flippant black and
white thinking that opens the door to
people who believe anything to say oh I
was right I was right the vaccines good
I'm glad there were vaccines yes but I
should be able to make my own medical
decisions you are not a nurse